In this video, we'll see how
to color our points by region
and how to add a linear
regression line to our plot.
Here we have our plot
from the last video,
where we've colored
the points dark red.
Now, let's color the
points by region instead.
This time, we want to add a
color option to our aesthetic,
since we're assigning a variable
in our data set to the colors.
To do this, we can type
ggplot, and then first give
the name of our
data, like before,
WHO, and then in our aesthetic,
we again specify that x = GNI
and y = FertilityRate.
But then we want to add
the option color = Region,
which will color the points
by the Region variable.
And then we just want to add
the geom_point function and hit
Enter.
Now, in our plot, we should
see that each point is colored
corresponding to the region
that country belongs in.
So the countries in
Africa are colored red,
the countries in the
Americas are colored gold,
Eastern Mediterranean
are colored green, etc.
This really helps
us see something
that we didn't see before.
The points from the
different regions
are really located in
different areas on the plot.
Let's now instead
color the points
according to the
country's life expectancy.
To do this, we just
have to hit the up arrow
to get back to our
ggplot line, and then
delete Region and
type LifeExpectancy.
Now, we should see that each
point is colored according
to the life expectancy
in that country.
Notice that before,
we were coloring
by a factor variable, Region.
So we had exactly
seven different colors
corresponding to the
seven different regions.
Here, we're coloring by
LifeExpectancy instead,
which is a numerical variable,
so we get a gradient of colors,
like this.
Lighter blue corresponds to
a higher life expectancy,
and darker blue corresponds
to a lower life expectancy.
Let's take a look at
a different plot now.
Suppose we were interested in
seeing whether the fertility
rate of a country was a good
predictor of the percentage
of the population under 15.
Intuitively, we would
expect these variables
to be highly correlated.
But before trying any
statistical models,
let's explore our
data with a plot.
So now, let's use the ggplot
function on the WHO data again,
but we're going to
specify in our aesthetic
that the x variable
should be FertilityRate,
and the y variable should
be the variable, Under15.
Again, we want to
add geom_point,
since we want a scatterplot.
This is really interesting.
It looks like the variables
are certainly correlated,
but as the fertility rate
increases, the variable,
Under15 starts increasing less.
So this doesn't really look
like a linear relationship.
But we suspect that a log
transformation of FertilityRate
will be better.
Let's give it a shot.
So go ahead and scroll
up in your R console
to the previous line, and
instead of x = FertilityRate,
we want x = log(FertilityRate).
And hit Enter.
Now this looks like a
linear relationship.
Let's try building in a
simple linear regression model
to predict the percentage
of the population under 15,
using the log of
the fertility rate.
So let's call our model,
model, and use the lm function
to predict Under15 using
as an independent variable
log(FertilityRate).
And our data set will be WHO.
Let's look at the
summary of our model.
It looks like the
log of FertilityRate
is indeed a great
predictor of Under15.
The variable is
highly significant,
and our R-squared is 0.9391.
Visualization was
a great way for us
to realize that the log
transformation would be better.
If we instead had just
used the FertilityRate,
the R-squared would
have been 0.87.
That's a pretty significant
decrease in R-squared.
So now, let's add this
regression line to our plot.
This is pretty easy in ggplot.
We just have to
add another layer.
So use the up arrow in
your R console to get back
to the plotting line, and then
add stat_smooth(method = "lm"),
and hit Enter.
Now, you should see a blue
line going through the data.
This is our regression line.
By default, ggplot will
draw a 95% confidence
interval shaded around the line.
We can change this
by specifying options
within the statistics layer.
So go ahead and scroll
up in the R console,
and after method = "lm", type
level = 0.99, and hit Enter.
This will give a 99%
confidence interval.
We could instead take away the
confidence interval altogether
by deleting level = 0.99
and typing se = FALSE.
Now, we just have the
regression line in blue.
We could also change the
color of the regression line
by typing as an option,
color = "orange".
Now, we have an orange
linear regression line.
As we've seen in this
lecture, scatterplots
are great for exploring data.
However, there are
many other ways
to represent data visually,
such as box plots, line charts,
histograms, heat maps,
and geographic maps.
In some cases, it may
be better to choose
one of these other ways
of visualizing your data.
Luckily, ggplot
makes it easy to go
from one type of visualization
to another, simply
by adding the appropriate
layer to the plot.
We'll learn more about other
types of visualizations
and how to create them
in the next lecture.
So what is the edge
of visualizations?
The WHO data that
we used here is
used by citizens,
policymakers, and organizations
around the world.
Visualizing the data
facilitates the understanding
of global health
trends at a glance.
By using ggplot in R, we're
able to visualize data
for exploration, modeling,
and sharing analytics results.